[BACKGROUND VOICES]
BARBARA STOCKING >> Hi, it's Barbara Stocking
from Oxfam again for those of you who might
have seen me before. Um-and I'm just gonna
talk about what I think that's going on here
in terms of growth in the economy.
It's really worrying that there's very little
talk about what's happening in developing
countries here. And yet, they're going to
be the ones who are going to be hit-um-with
some of them slightly later in the whole-as
the-the whole economy changes. Obviously very
differently depending on the different countries
where the emerging economies are sending out
consumer goods out or people are losing on
their _____ like the Democratic Republic of
Congo. So I think we've got a long way to
go with poor people and I wish it would pop
up on the agenda a bit higher here.
The other thing that I am concerned about
is the-is life change-and the way actually-I
do think in the debates it has not stood out
to the economy. And yet this is such an absolutely
critical year.
But I'm also worried because I've been in
on some sessions-um-on-on climate change where
people here just don't seem to get what people
in the south feel about this. Um-there is
enormous anger. Ah-not much-very few people,
as they probably don't know but amongst the
elites in a number of emerging countries about
what's been done through pollution, and the
fact that the-the industrialized countries
really need to put some money in through the
deal for poor countries to adapt now. And
I don't think most of the people here get
that that's part of the deal. And that most
people in the south economy are talking about
this issue as an issue of justice.
Um-so I think there's a long way to go and
obviously I'm spending my time going around
to the various meetings trying to make sure
that those viewpoints get put in.